Hey guys, it's Gigguk and let's talk about... uh...
What?
Hey guys, it's Gigguk and let's talk about ha, ha, ha, HA, HA, HA-
Hey guys, it's Gigguk and let's talk about- *gagging noises*
*various choking noises in tune with the screen shakes*
HEY GUYS, IT'S GIGGUK, AND TODAY, LET'S TALK ABOUT
Code Geass Opening: "Colors"
JIBUN
No
You see, if you haven't heard the news that's been spreading around the anime community for the past day,
Code Geass is officially getting a sequel called "Lelouch of the Resurrection"!
And yes, Lelouch is the main character.
And, a lot of people have been asking me what I think,
and you know, who, who, who can tell right now?
Who, who, who can really tell?
WHO CAN FUCKING TELL?
So I think it's just the best option that we all just remain optimistic
'cause it's just the best course of action and,
you know, let's have faith that Sunrise know what their doing because, you know, it's their IP
and I'm sure they wouldn't shit all over it intentionally.
*classical music with rich people laughing*
Viewer: What actual idiot would actually review Code Geass and give it a nine out of ten?
Who the fucking casual git?
Who- who the fuck is this person?!
I mean, why should we be cautious when like,
the ending of R2 is one of the most conclusive endings in anime or something
I mean, it's not like the plot threads were perfectly tied up in the most satisfying ways possible,
leaving the decision of whether Lelouch was alive or not up to our imagination.
No, no, you're- you're- you're totally right, there's nothing to worry ab-
Hey guys! Jenna from the Flip Flop Barnyard here.
I'm getting ready to milk Gerdy and I wanted to just give you guys a little how-to on milking a cow.
Code Geass R2 Opening: "O2"
And that's it!
At least there's one thing that we can all universally agree on,
we can all revive the dead Code Geass memes now, boys!
Whoo! Yeah, let's go!
*You Spin Me Right Round in the background*
"WHAT DO YOU MEAN YOU'RE AT SOUP?"
"I MEAN, I'M AT SOUP."
"WHAT STORE ARE YOU IN?"
"I'M AT THE SOUP STORE."
And now, a quick word from our sponsor.
Hi yes, I'd like to order an extra large margarita pizza please?
Uh, just with stuffed crust.
Uh no, I don't want any extra Code Geass with it, please.
No, no, no, I, I just said that I don't want any fucking extra Code Geass with-
Alright, so a lot of people are pretty surprised
or pissed off that they're bringing Lelouch back,
but, in fact, everyone missed the concrete evidence that Lelouch was alive all along.
You see a strong theory was at the end of R2, it was Lelouch who was driving this cart here.
Now what you didn't know is that if we zoom in on the cart here,
uh, zoom in a bit closer, and just enhance it a bit,
we can quite clearly see that Sunrise had planned this all along.
And you know, they were obviously waiting for just the right moment to spring this on us.
BUT HEY, THAT'S JUST A THEORY.
AN ANIME THE-
*dramatic music*
Alright, let's take a step back for a second and have a serious talk about this.
I'm sure that a lot of us remember Code Geass fondly as
the anime that grabbed the entire community nearly a decade ago,
and this announcement has come with very mixed feelings.
Some of you are hyped as hell at the prospect of more Code Geass,
and some of you are very worried about the prospect of a continuation,
of which I am definitely in the latter camp.
Don't get me wrong, I love Code Geass and if this turns out to be a great sequel,
fucking brilliant!
But we have to wonder what the true purpose is of Sunrise
making a continuation to one of their most beloved anime franchises.
Whether this was something that was planned out that can actually properly work,
or just a quick cash-grab.
Which considering how well the ending wrapped up everything in the second season,
and how a direct continuation was quite unnecessary, a lot of us are afraid it's going to be.
We can only speculate at this point as there is minimal information about it,
and whatever side you're on, it's best to keep an open mind as
Yes, this is actually happening!
Personally, I remain hopeful, but catious of the possibility of this continuation tarnishing
one of the most conclusive and, in my opinion, one of the best anime endings regardless of-
Inner Gigguk: Oh god, what happened to the writing in the middle of this season?!
And I would've preferred it if Sunrise just pulled a Gundam
and just continued the timeline without rehashing the main character.
Yes, if it sucks, we can just pretend it didn't exist,
but I love the charm of the original ending was not knowing
whether Lelouch truly did die sacrificing himself for the greater good and-
Inner Gigguk: Sunrise, are you going to tell me that this epic ending was all for nothing in the end?!
In conclusion, JIBUN WO?
More like JIBUN woah, calm down guys, let's wait and see how this plays out
'cause it could suck, but you know, it could be good too.
Hopefully.
Maybe.
Meanwhile, in opposite world:
Aww yeah, more Code Geass Pachinko machines, baby!
Whoo, exactly what I wanted!
Code Geass R2 Opening: "O2"